(AUDIENCE CHANTING LARRY'S NAME)
>> Larry: YES!
THANK YOU!
I APPRECIATE IT.
YES!
WE'RE BACK!
THANK YOU!
WELCOME TO THE "THE NIGHTLY
SHOW"!
I'M LARRY WILMORE!
LAST NIGHT WAS THE 87th ANNUAL
ACADEMY AWARDS.
WHAT A GREAT SHOW. IT REALLY
WAS.
AND I HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
I WAS A LITTLE CONCERNED BECAUSE
THE OSCARS WERE SORT OF SET UP
TO BE LIKE A NEW YORK CITY
WINTER -- LONG AND WHITE.
TO BE FAIR.
BUT I THOUGHT NEIL PATRICK
HARRIS DID A GOOD JOB
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT.
>> TONIGHT WE HONOR HOLLYWOOD'S
BEST AND WHITEST -- SORRY,
BRIGHTEST.
>> Larry: SEE, THAT'S A PRO
RIGHT THERE.
YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THE AWKWARD
RACIAL REALITY OF THE EVENING
AND MOVE ON.
WELL DONE, SIR.
WHAT ELSE?
>> OCTAVIA SPENCER,
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS TONIGHT,
DO NOT TAKE YOUR EYES OFF THE
BRIEFCASE, GOT IT?
NO BATHROOM BREAKS.
NO CHITCHAT.
>> Larry: HOLD ON A SECOND.
YOU CAN'T MAKE A JOKE ABOUT HOW
WHITE THE OSCARS ARE AND THEN
TURN AROUND AND LITERALLY MAKE
OCTAVIA SPENCER "THE HELP"!
NOT WELL DONE, SIR.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE THAT
BACK.
LOOK, THESE OSCARS WERE SO WHITE
THAT WHEN LONNIE LYNN AND JOHN
STEPHENS WON FOR BEST SONG, THEY
COULDN'T EVEN USE THEIR BLACK
NAMES.
THAT'S RIGHT, COMMON'S REAL NAME
IS LONNIE LYNN.
GOOD CALL ON THE NAME CHANGE,
LONNIE.
JUST SAYING.
BUT THE THEME OF THE NIGHT WAS
SPEECHES WITH SUBSTANCE.
>> IT'S OUR TIME TO HAVE WAGE
EQUALITY ONCE AND FOR ALL.
>> THIS BRIDGE TRANSCENDS RACE,
GENDER, RELIGION.
>> WE ARE WITH YOU, WE SEE YOU,
WE LOVE YOU.
>> THAT KID OUT THERE WHO FEELS
LIKE SHE IS WEIRD OR SHE IS
DIFFERENT OR SHE DOESN'T FIT IN
ANYWHERE, STAY WEIRD.
STAY DIFFERENT.
>> Larry: WOW.
STAY WEIRD, STAY DIFFERENT.
THAT'S A VERY GOOD MESSAGE. I
LIKE IT
LET'S SEE IF ANYONE TOOK THAT
NOTE.
>> YOU, YOU MY DARLING, MY
BEAUTIFUL, MY WICKEDLY TALENTED
IDINA MENZEL.
>> YOU GOT IT RIGHT.
YAY.
>> Larry: THAT WAS HANDS DOWN
THE WEIRDEST MOMENT OF THE
NIGHT.
NO, SERIOUSLY, TRAVOLTA, PUT
YOUR HANDS DOWN.
STAY WEIRD, NOT CREEPY.
ALL RIGHT, ENOUGH ABOUT THE
OSCARS.
WHAT I REALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
TONIGHT ARE SOME RECENT COMMENTS
MADE BY AMERICA'S MAYOR.
NO, NOT HIM.
THE ONE WITH A BIGGER HEAD.
YEAH, HIM.
LAST WEEK, WHILE SPEAKING AT A
FUNDRAISER FOR REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTIAL HOPEFUL SCOTT
WALKER, GIULIANI HAD THIS TO SAY
ABOUT PRESIDENTIAL ACTUAL BARACK
OBAMA.
>> GIULIANI TOUCHED OFF A
FIRESTORM WHEN HE SAID EARLIER
THIS WEEK, "I KNOW THIS IS A
HORRIBLE THING TO SAY, BUT I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT THE PRESIDENT
LOVES AMERICA.
HE DOESN'T LOVE YOU.
AND HE DOESN'T LOVE ME ."
>> LARRY: HE DOESN'T LOVE YOU.
HE DOESN'T LOVE ME.
HE DOESN'T LOVE YOU...
HE LOVES ME!
SINCE WHEN DOES GIULIANI GET TO
DECLARE WHO LOVES THE COUNTRY?
WHO PUT HIM IN CHARGE OF COUNTRY
LOVE?
ISN'T THAT TOBY KEITH'S JOB?
OR LONNIE LYNN'S?
I'M SORRY.
IT WAS JUST THE MOST SHOCKING
REVELATION OF THE NIGHT.
BUT RUDY WASN'T DONE RIPPING
OBAMA.
WHAT ELSE DID HE SAY?
>> HE WASN'T BROUGHT UP THE WAY
YOU WERE BROUGHT UP AND I WAS
BROUGHT UP, THROUGH LOVE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Larry: HE WASN'T BROUGHT UP
THROUGH LOVE OF THIS COUNTRY.
SO THAT MEANS HE WAS BROUGHT UP
THROUGH HATE OF THIS COUNTRY?
MR. PRESIDENT, WHO HATE-RAISED
YOU?
>> I WAS RAISED WITH THE HELP OF
A WHITE GRANDFATHER WHO SURVIVED
A DEPRESSION TO SERVE IN
PATTON'S ARMY DURING WORLD
WAR II AND A WHITE GRANDMOTHER
WHO WORKED ON A BOMBER ASSEMBLY
LINE IN FORT LEVENWORTH WHILE HE
WAS OVERSEAS.
>> Larry: W.W. DEUCE AND
FACTORIES?
IT DOESN'T GET MORE "I LOVE
AMERICA" THAN THAT.
UNLESS YOUR GRANDMA MADE
AMERICAN FLAGS WHILE WORKING IN
AN APPLE PIE FACTORY.
SO WHAT ELSE IS DIFFERENT ABOUT
OBAMA?
MAN, I'M...
MMM...
NO, NO, NO...
I'M...
NO, I'M...
I'M REALLY TRYING MY BEST NOT TO
USE THE RACE CARD.
GETTING DIFFICULT.
NO, YOU KNOW, (BLEEP) THAT
(BLEEP).
THAT'S RACIST.
YES, THAT'S RIGHT.
I USED THE RACE CARD.
AND YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE RUDY, WHEN YOU WERE
TRYING TO EXPLAIN YOURSELF, YOU
USED THE 9/11 CARD.
>> YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT OBAMA
DIDN'T LIVE THROUGH
SEPTEMBER 11th.
I DID.
(BOOING)
>> Larry: THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
LIVE THROUGH SEPTEMBER 11th?
ARE YOU SAYING HE WAS BORN 13
YEARS AGO?
IS THAT WHY THEY WANTED TO SEE
HIS BIRTH CERTIFICATE?
IT'S NOT THAT HE WAS BORN IN
KENYA, IT'S THAT HE WAS BORN IN
OCTOBER OF 2001?
I GUESS HOPE AND CHANGE MEANT
HOPING HIS VOICE WOULD CHANGE BY
THE ELECTION.
RUDY, I'M SORRY.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO CUT OFF THE
DEFENSE OF YOUR RACIST
STATEMENT.
PLEASE CONTINUE.
>> YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT OBAMA
DIDN'T LIVE THROUGH
SEPTEMBER 11 -- I DID.
PRESIDENT OBAMA DIDN'T ALMOST,
YOU KNOW, HAVE A BUILDING FALL
ON HIM -- MYSELF AND MY POLICE
COMMISSIONER AND MY FIRE
COMMISSIONER DID.
>> Larry: ARE YOU DRUNK?
EVERY AMERICAN LIVED THROUGH
9/11.
NOT JUST AMERICA, BUT MOST OF
THE WORLD CAME TOGETHER AFTER
THAT HAPPENED.
IN FACT, IT WAS SUCH A POWERFUL,
INTOXICATING EVENT THAT FOR A
BRIEF, SHINING MOMENT, THE
ENTIRE WORLD FORGOT WHAT A
COLOSSAL PRICK YOU ARE.
THAT'S HOW BIG IT WAS.
IT WAS HUGE!
(APPLAUSE)
IT WAS HUGE.
NOW THAT GIULIANI HAS GOTTEN SO
MUCH HEAT, HE'S BACKPEDALING
LIKE A RUSSIAN BEAR ON A BICYCLE
AT THE CIRCUS.
HE WROTE AN OP-ED SAYING...
>> MY BLUNT LANGUAGE SUGGESTING
THAT THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T LOVE
AMERICA NOTWITHSTANDING, I
DIDN'T INTEND TO QUESTION
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S MOTIVES OR THE
CONTENT OF HIS HEART.
(AUDIENCE BOOING)
>> Larry: OKAY, AND MY BLUNT
LANGUAGE REGARDING RUDY
GIULIANI'S STATEMENT
NOTWITHSTANDING STILL STANDS.
IT'S (BLEEP) RACIST.
(APPLAUSE)
GIULIANI'S BIGGEST BEEF, EVEN
AFTER HIS FEEBLE ATTEMPT AT AN
EXPLANATION WAS THAT OBAMA
CRITICIZES AMERICA TOO MUCH.
>> I DON'T HEAR FROM HIM WHAT I
HEARD FROM HARRY TRUMAN, WHAT I
HEARD FROM BILL CLINTON, WHAT I
HEARD FROM JIMMY CARTER, WHICH
IS THESE WONDERFUL WORDS ABOUT
WHAT A GREAT COUNTRY WE ARE,
WHAT AN EXCEPTIONAL COUNTRY WE
ARE.
>> Larry: YOU'RE RIGHT.
HE'S NEVER SAID THAT.
>> AMERICA IS A PLACE WHERE ALL
THINGS ARE POSSIBLE.
THIS NATION IS GREAT BECAUSE WE
BUILT IT TOGETHER.
I BELIEVE IN AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM WITH EVERY FIBER
OF MY BEING.
LOVE AND CHARITY AND DUTY AND
PATRIOTISM...
THAT'S WHAT MAKES AMERICA GREAT.
WE WILL CONTINUE OUR JOURNEY
FORWARD AND REMIND THE WORLD
JUST WHY IT IS WE LIVE IN THE
GREATEST NATION ON EARTH!
(APPLAUSE)
THANK YOU, AMERICA, GOD BLESS
YOU.
>> Larry: OKAY, FINE.
OBAMA LOVES AMERICA.
JUST NOT AS MUCH AS RUDY
GIULIANI LOVES 9/11.
OR AS MUCH AS I LOVE THAT
COMMON'S REAL NAME IS LONNIE
LYNN.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.